the jurogan experience you must get this
a lot the people people say things like
uh i know
uh well i do i do this in a kind of
self-deprecating way off and say well
i've been lucky in this that yeah and
you know very well that some you know a
lot of life is luck for sure but some of
life is luck
being in the right place at the right
time being able just being able-bodied
but then a lot of it is and it's
underplayed is is you also work hard yes
like um
and i realized some time ago that i i
use because i'm
born in britain i have that natural
tendency to like under
play something oh well i'm just lucky in
that and somebody said to me you should
you shouldn't do that you know you do
work very hard
and i thought yes but like saying well
i've been lucky in that is a nice way to
say to other people oh i haven't really
had any input and
you don't need to particularly either
it's a sort of
it's an it's a flattering thing to say
to somebody else and which ignores which
ignores
what something actually i quote at the
end of the book wonderful phrase of
branch ricky i came across we said uh
luck is the residue of design
luck is the residue of design
like what a lot of what we call luck
it has come about
through something other than chance
like so i used to say
you're lucky to be born in america
and on one level that's true which is
like you could have been born in in the
great pool things you could have
been born in mogadishu and it'd be a lot
worse
but there's also something that covers
up which is
the luck is
is that people before you made good
choices
that meant that you are in a situation
which is more optimal
and it's not simply luck
that you have in america
the right to freedom of speech
like that's not simply like it's luck in
that you were born here as opposed to
mogadishu but it's not luck that america
ended up with that situation it is
it is the residue of design it's the
consequence of men and women making good
decisions
prudent decisions like not being
crazily short-termist
setting up a estate well
you know there's a great description in
a novel by hillary mantel about the
french revolution in the first days of
the meeting of the parliament after
they've killed the king
and she says um
you know they wanted to talk about
rights
she said she says i'm paraphrasing she
says something like this was the day to
talk about laws
but rights were more attractive to talk
about so they put off the discussion of
laws for another day
you know
and that's how you get what you got in
the terror and everything else and this
is the thing is that
what you we have to find a better way to
understand what we often mean by luck
you have luck in your life
sometimes because other people
have made good judgments that are
effectively for you before your time
yeah you know your politicians your
family and others it's not just
it's not just some wild whirly gig it's
also
make prudent decisions make wise
decisions work hard
and a lot more and you'll find that you
are what we call lucky
or luckier
don't do any of that stuff put
everything off all the time be lazy
be um
unmotivated
um
you know blame other people all the time
uh for things that i think you could
correct yourself and you will find you
are the type of person that is described
as unlucky
it's it's it's it's
and it's the same with countries there
are countries we describe as unlucky
like
venezuela was like they weren't just
unlucky
they had the people on
[ __ ] unluckiest people in the world
mom practically but like it became a
what we would call an unlucky country
because politicians made catastrophic
decisions
you know they have yet they have the
same energy sources uh same energy
resources as norway
it's it's better to be in norway than in
venezuela and there's a reason which is
the people made better decisions
and
we we're very
unwilling to identify what those
decisions are
and what it is that leads to a good
outcome or a bad outcome which is really
strange because american exceptionalism
was always predicated on the idea that
you work hard and you can make something
in this country it was a big part of the
motto of what it meant to be an american